some of the Americans who fled the
corona virus outbreak in China will
finally get to go home today hundreds of
others though are still being
quarantined around the u.s. Chinese
officials confirm this morning that dr.
Liu Ziming director of one of the
hospitals at the epicenter of the
outbreak has died of the disease Carter
Evans is at Travis Air Force Base that's
north of San Francisco where the first
group of American evacuate to be
released we just hope that the community
that we're going back to accepts us and
is not afraid of us Sam Roth is headed
to Travis Air Force Base today to
reunite with his wife and two young
daughters after about a month apart they
were among the first Americans evacuated
from the epicenter of the outbreak Roth
says they've stayed healthy throughout
their isolation they've been provided
plenty of food three meals a day they
have a comfortable hotel to stay in we
just landed Kurenai but others like
Jerry Surratt E Goldman and her husband
Carl weren't so lucky they were among
the more than 300 Americans to arrive in
the US on chartered planes yesterday
mid-flight Carl developed respiratory
symptoms and was isolated on the plane
their flight landed outside Omaha
Nebraska and Carl was taken to a
hospital after testing positive for the
corona virus Goldman's husband is among
12 others being treated at the
University of Nebraska Medical Center
clear these were folks that hadn't had a
high index of suspicion that came to us
and so all of them we knew that we would
evaluate them now back in Japan there
are aiming to start trial soon using an
HIV treatment for the carota virus
meanwhile concern is growing about the
more than 2,000 passengers and crew
aboard the cruise ship Westar Dam after
one of those passengers tested positive
when they disembarked in Cambodia Gail
all right Carter thank you very much